yup sex everyone hey what's up Joe hold
on I am and I just get into arguments
for the makeup sex we're just arguing
about the movie crash oh why doesn't
Jimmy really liked it and I thought it
was really really stupid I thought it
was great it was it was [ __ ] in the
end Wow
then I'm outnumbered I think you were
those guys that just likes to argue with
the masses who me yes like I'm glad it
was so good yeah yeah I loved it yeah
not everyone nice and moist I feel like
you do yeah well you know I know you're
rocky - I got to tell you jo koy I'm a
little counterculture you never know
quite which way I'm gonna go yeah yeah
for sure
what's going on man let much dude I'm in
New York this is oh are you doing a gig
this is you're promoting and glorious
inglorious pranksters Thursdays at 3
o'clock on laugh-out-loud comm are you
doing a gig here too or no yeah I'm
doing this Tonight Show oh come on it's
a good gig yeah it's funny when they
tell you to run your TV set at a club
and it's just like why why are we doing
this it never goes well other clubs it's
not the same audience you know I mean
like I got in my head but it's just like
you got to sneak it in between stuff you
got to go in between certain comics and
you're just like this isn't going to
work right now why am I doing this I
can't be natural about the room because
you don't want to go okay and you know
you've got seven minutes or eight
minutes and you got a [ __ ] you got to
do your set yeah I got four and a half
that I'm trying to knock out it looks
like how where do I put this did you run
it last night at guy yeah I ran it last
night I was watching your set trying to
find like we're in it it was a part
where I didn't curse before the piping
and how's everyone doing tonight good to
be here how long has it set it sits for
a fort a half Wow for now over five
that's very shortly you know I want to
go to fit no they know better now yeah
they want yes under five now that's they
want it's it's yeah keep it are they
getting you too friendly yeah how many
looks like the new thing now Wow where
the hose me but uh I've been running
this thing everywhere man it's like
going back to training then I was like
coffee houses I was on vacation I just
went up at an open mic and just did it
just to do it just to do it
yeah now you have cue cards and you got
do you have to use teleprompter our cue
cards he only uses cue cards so that
that's I like that so I have a couple of
bullet points must be from his SNL days
he's probably just useless right yeah
right yeah yeah but I'll use them a lot
of guys yeah demux I think it looks cool
or two I think there's just like that
nostalgic look to see like you know
every time they pan over to the camera
should I break you see a bunch of guys
squirreling on the board playing on it
that's tbh yeah you get to keep the card
I am right night show it's my first time
with Jimmy you got you got it yeah you
got to keep your first right your first
you get the card from the desk that he
reads off of god be given back yeah I
got to remember they like the cue
carpets a little I got a little bit the
first Leno I do it's a little blue card
yeah because it's easier to get that
frame then who the [ __ ] wants a bunch of
giant cue card yeah yeah you bring that
on the claim you look stupid yeah yeah
yeah I was on The Tonight Show by that a
ticket so are we on with you know on I
only want okay Andy Cohen okay yeah it's
gonna be good that's it got your great
show oh yeah good show so you feel
nervous about I don't know no not at all
I was never cited TV time like so used
to cursing and having freedom yeah my
mouth I don't know it just shuts off
when I do it but the I'm not nervous
anymore I don't know just TV do you know
what we did that Chelsea all the times
right yeah it's just like that was every
week there was like hey just don't curse
don't curse and then Chelsea just you
know dick [ __ ] the whole I would sit
there go okay she's just got a lot of
[ __ ] by the way for [ __ ] that racism
tweet yes Oh people are killing it for
that day she said something about and
she you know sometimes you say something
a lot of times when you're online it's a
moment in your life you see something
stupid but she said something about some
guys were arrested for like mocking in
Germany they arrested from what sore
tweeze its mocking Nazis mocking making
fun of it at in Germany and yeah I did
see that yeah and she wrote something
like hey wouldn't it be great if we had
laws what to Chinese guys arrested in
Berlin from making Nazi salutes would it
be nice to have laws here for people who
think racism is funny
and she got a beating for that yes she's
made racial we'd always like it's a
comic you I think there was a picture of
a Sarah Silverman oh yeah yeah hop in
there I think
he did she tagged that photo or
something I don't know that's what I
read I saw that tweet and then I saw
Sara's picture dressed up as Hitler I
think I think somebody tagged her on it
is that what it was okay like it could
be a big problem for you and your friend
yeah well it's almost like you just
can't when you come out and you start
saying what can be easily going to Isaac
United so hey don't do this or that then
people just start calling around on her
dirty jokes yeah yeah yeah you don't
ever want to start telling comedians yet
people will go through your old [ __ ] so
quickly do you want your [ __ ] rifle
through my comedians [ __ ] looking for
problems yeah you ought to see my
history though the stuff is that's why I
just don't even say anything at all I
can't yeah living lately I just let it
go yeah I'm not gonna comment you live
and let live and let live I'm in no
position to ever [ __ ] have a bunch of
comedians I'd like to say what someone
should make fun of I would be [ __ ]
called a hypocrite immediately yes very
good comedians have their days free so
all they're going to be doing is
scrolling through all your Jimdo you're
already - yeah what about it yeah Google
has everything that you're looking for
oh yeah oh yeah my Julie did that - yeah
oh no no man Joe Coyte black jokes right
this way wait a bit do you remember
Kevin Hart told the story about doing a
gig with you where he was headlining was
a radio station gig with a black a
station in LA and Kevin was the
headliner and you went on before and he
said he said [ __ ] he died going on if
I would never follow Joe quite a big gig
and his sellers one thing but to go on a
you know I can arena event 11 [ __ ] that
and he said you buried him and he was
really [ __ ] that was a power 106
you don't power 106 I don't have ever
done it oh don't you urban stations if
they don't help me draw and I never feel
like I'm doing well
Pacific Rim like on the radio yeah I
don't I love [ __ ] I do this way show
I love you drive me crazy man I think I
think you're second longer
no I think I don't say stuff like you're
just like what are you talking about I'm
wrong what are you talking about I hope
I'm or your worst enemy Jim I think I'm
giving right now you if I go to your
worst enemy he always says that I like
Jim you the biggest drop in your danger
sex
sorry sure your on you you you crushing
you draw and if you need your sexual
stuff on urban radio they would get a
[ __ ] kick out of you
very racist I want everyone to remember
that yeah Google that was right there
urban is not that's not any specific
race hey man crash the movie sucks and
you know people love sex jokes all these
Jim but no I times too many
doesn't even like crash I wonder if I
notice it like I wonder have some
business before do I notice if somebody
black in the crowd doesn't like me more
but like I've seen too many times this
look doesn't work on the radio yeah
that's just a look but I've seen that
look at those and it's a different
you're too nervous Joe they all look at
you like that man yeah sure like man
that was funny what was wrong your face
yeah no I've always felt like oh just
the I'm waiting piano impress me look
yes I've open for Ares fears a couple
times and right when I walk out it's
just a sea of faces or gonna be like why
why yeah look who here is just [ __ ]
blowing arias again say China but that's
what it looks like candid is amazing I
should get back to Kevin because um from
here to promote the gym network lol
never has his own as is on that way Amy
that show inglorious pranksters man and
it's just like this guy is non-stop gym
yeah he really does non-stop and it
comes out of nowhere it's like yeah I'm
launching the show I'm launching the
network and then like the next day it's
like I'm running a marathon about yeah
slow down but explain the network though
I don't it's like an online app yeah
it's just all comedy and I think the guy
has bought so much comedy content and
it's and it's great because I feel like
and I love Comedy Central Jim it's just
sure I feel like they've we've done and
founded a different I did not set a
comedian so yeah yeah and I and now that
I stood what they kind of went away from
calm in that comedy but you know mean
like stand-up that content that we used
to watch on how many something like you
you'd watch every special on Comedy
Central I feel like you you can't go
there anymore and I think lol he's got
all that content he's got everything
that's funny on this network and I love
him and I'm glad to be a part of it plus
I have Kevin's an animal
really promotes everything right and
when you read his book you realize the
way he was raised because his mother
wanted to keep him from from like being
[ __ ] off in the gang
she was constantly busy obsessively busy
and I read that book I've known him for
a long time ago that's why he's this guy
yeah it made perfect sense that his
mother [ __ ] drilled into him do [ __ ]
do [ __ ] do he was always busy reading
the problem with the neighborhood kid
there's no like sitting around there's
no like oh I just need some time to
myself oh yeah what are we doing out
what are we doing now what are we doing
that's funny that I never thought of
that
yeah I'm time for myself I never I'm
reminding oh yeah yeah I'm gonna I did
decompress in there Oh mom I just needed
some time for me just a little time for
me and I'll be right back with the
family but dinner's ready I'm taking
some time right yeah yeah I'll be there
for dessert if you don't mind I'm gonna
clean my room mind off things
what the [ __ ] is wrong with jr. so what
do you do actually in the show I'm the
host of inglorious pranksters it it's a
you know it's a prank show viral videos
and I just host it and then we interview
the guys that did it oh okay it's so
smart though Jim it's like it's like
it's almost like free TV it's like yeah
like you find all this content and go
how can I use this and they found a
great way to do it right it's kind of
like what Byron Allen did I mean he buys
a network Rob creates a network and he's
um he's off [ __ ]
multi-multi-millionaire he's in here my
mom but his mom tonight his mom I think
helped him like finance a lot of those
shows but it's just like brilliant
though it's like why am I going to sit
there and wait for it when I could do it
myself and he did that's exactly what he
did and if he said 24 hours of that show
pretty much the comics unleashed yeah
yeah you know do you know what he did he
just went to every market that is like
okay when does NBC go off the air and
it's like okay well I'll buy that spot
so it's the commercial spots that they
write all those infomercial hours and he
buys them these right here I'll put my
show on that and I think he sells his
own ads on and now look he's got this I
see he's made two movies
these are very smart dude yeah another
crush I can't remember the moves I just
went to watch when I saw it I saw a
Jackie Jackie transom yeah the whole
production company and I'm like damn
this you guys have
you'd be willing to do the work too
though IGN he's a hard work I got to be
willing to wait a while cuz it's
knocking he's not going to make that
money right away yeah yeah that's my
favorite story about Byron Allen when he
first did The Tonight Show Johnny Carson
they go who would you like to meet in
this business because I guess he was
like 18 or 19 I'm messing up the story
sure don't quote me but he said he wrote
on the Walker there we'll wrote on that
wall the Jimmy Carter Johnny Carson roll
anyone I would love to meet Byron Allen
I think that is the coolest comment I
tired Allen you know that yeah you wrote
that on the wall then he wants to meet
fire now I want to meet my Byron Allen I
guess that was his when he was a kid
that was the the guy that he was looking
at when he was a kid to be a star on TV
like Oh wirings doing AMA doing do you
remember uh do you remember him uh on
real people yeah that's that's why he
wanted me by Ranieri because the real
people well you're saying by who are we
saying Eddie Murphy wrote that unlikely
you said Byron Allen's first tonight so
I misunderstand why don't that be
horribly yeah yeah because yeah I
thought he was saying I want to be
myself yes I thought it was very bad
thing to do I aspired me
there we go that's why I was confused I
miss him that didn't make sense um oh
yeah real people who he's also got a
skip Stevenson who died Stevenson man
and she was so good yeah welcome Sarah
Purcell
welcome to real people or was it I loved
it it was like what do they featured
oddities and people who could do
interesting thing that was like that's
incredible yeah kind of like that your
your ankle Quarter IV another outlet for
me to flick corners I think you would
have been Ike we look up real people it
would have been on one of those uh I've
done that as an adult yes keep this
thing going career for ya
whenever do this ridiculous radio this
was John my ankles can do oh wait I
think it was like one ex football player
or something like that was really
talking to us that's incredible that's
incredible it was John barber who I did
not remember Sarah Purcell I remember
skip Stephenson who died and Byron Allen
Wow and how many years of that I guess
he was Bill Rafferty doing stand-up at
like 14 Byron I was working to do like
small he's older than he's letting on
like a lot of times people are saying
when you start to do the backwards math
like I started I was sick you're lying
I never met by renowned oh it was on
from
1984 and what was that's incredible on
that was that was like a real like 70
show Ripley's Believe It or Not with a
show people doing crazy weird [ __ ] yeah
I could have gotten on that one too you
could have won one of those shows would
have had [ __ ] they were all the
conveying borders already 84 they
brought the gong show back soon I know
but it's all fake like is that the
people on the show like I know they're
like improv guys like that's not good
yeah it's so good I want a guy that
works at Starbucks it's like King Kong
shows my shot yeah yeah I said to say
the truth I'm weirded out that like Mike
Meyers who's hilarious yeah like his
return to show business after all this
time is in that character and there's no
acknowledgment of actual Mike Meyers
well they're not even saying anything
about Mike know what you excited her so
he's doing you know have you seen the
new gong show no I well I think well our
net is the executive yeah or something
behind it so watch the first couple
episodes and I mean it's fun like it's a
gong show but Mike Meyers is the host
but he's doing this weird British kind
of old-school game show host character
okay I got a ton of makeup on she
doesn't look like Mike Meyers got ton of
makeup he's got the tux on the wig on
and there's no never any acknowledged
editor did it's him he's just doing a
character yeah I can I can i yeah man
can go weird so much that sucks that
they already let it out that it's him
like why'd it just keep it like a top
secret that way like season 3 he peels
his face back and it's a we do character
because you can't tell it's him but in
the Robin Williams element we haven't
talked yet in the promo for the show it
was like this is Mike Myers has been
taken by a comic calling himself
call me Maitland Holly Megan so where
did this guy come from the network will
not confirm it but I have a source that
is in fact Mike Myers okay so if people
know it's him they could kind of outed
him on it they did yeah although I think
when they were first promos I think this
is all just like it was part of it okay
in the beginning they want Mike Myers to
bring people to watch it I thought yeah
exactly
it's none other than much weird yeah
it's very yeah it does look like Robin
he looks like wow that's kind of cool
though yeah dude the Robin Williams
story you know who's playing because he
looks just like yeah
like it does yeah uh-huh trying to get
into the Asian I could do the vo yeah
you can go ahead with the audition that
Jim just goes in for the audition that's
all he does he doesn't even read this I
can't do the voice sick huh yes huh did
you like it ha ha ha I only do that and
I'm done
Edwin that was one of my favorite
moments in the stand of is working with
Robin
where was it they was at the Laugh
Factory he just cremated it spot he did
he did three spots and uh for the Oscars
because he was he's gonna do a
nomination but he wanted to do some
stand-up before he did it and he can't
he was working on it and he kept he kept
coming in and he was like he was asked
all the time do you mind if I come just
do like five minutes and I'm like are
you gay five hours waiting for this
moment sir he was an amazingly nice job
the first time I met him was I think in
1998 he came to the Comedy Cellar and I
still remember the night it was Manny
was there the old cellar owner is a
picture of Robin and Manny together and
in the cellar and he came in and he went
on and he came out to talk to all the
communities and me and Colin went
downstairs I've told this story before
but kind and just to kind of you want to
be shitty to him you know I mean and
then Colin we were watching it was all
topical stuff there and it was [ __ ]
brilliant and Colin son of a [ __ ]
really does have a genius stretch you
couldn't deny great the stuff he was
doing was he was [ __ ] incredible and
God and he came up but he hung with the
kimmy he was [ __ ] awesome he was a
really nice dude it's crazy because you
see the levels of famous to because that
was the same year I think Chris was
hosting the Oscars so they were all
working out and they're all just going
through the you know black Mexican
province and so Robbie comes it I mean
uh Chris comes in and does his set but
you know took like forever for everyone
to sit down and stop clapping because
Chris was on stretcher and you're like
god there's no one more famous and Chris
right now there's no one and then here
comes Robyn and I mean it would not stop
man like people were like just running
up to the stage I remember this one lady
ran all the way up to the stage of the
camera to take a picture and he's like I
got a camera too [ __ ] let's go and he
starts doing like
phone taking pictures with it was just
like genius to watch it man yeah he was
a weird guy they have a bunch of
celebrities go on like you know Seinfeld
Trump's anybody sure
Ray Romano can go on whenever he wants
these guys but Robin I think kind of
whenever there was a bunch of comedians
it was no one that was higher on the
ladder than him doing other guys that
were almost as high but there was I
think anybody higher on the ladder as a
stand-up yeah yeah you know no no
totally why did I get Bob Saget did a
set left and found out that Robin was
and he came back just to watch Robin
yeah yeah awesome yeah it was it was
totally cool yeah I mean I'm Eddie
Murphy going on would be a big deal oh
god she ant yeah I've been to a show
where he was just in the audience I
walked down the stairs and the show
stopped really stopped yeah he walked
just walk down yeah watch your set uh
yeah like this ya know he was in Memphis
yeah he's great man you know he loves
telling you you seen him all right I
never seen him in person what any movies
warning I would love to me I've never
met on to my knowledge never in the same
room of them oh I thought he drops in it
never saw at the cellar Wow no if he was
there I just didn't see him he may have
come in but I was trying to talk Ricky
Gervais something going whenever he
comes on the show like or the cellar
Kenny one not go he's a guy he's got it
hung out once I think with Louie but
he's never actually gone to go on come I
don't know I think some guys like he
would crush him and would that be great
to see him just go up at the cellar and
I think once you've been going on there
for a while I think a lot of guys once
they get famous and that room has such a
history they don't dice only went on
there one time like a lot of guys don't
go on there for some I don't know why
it's a lack of comfort there because
they didn't come up yeah I don't know
any sense I'm not just not sure like
they think the room is not what it
really is
mmm I don't know what else is on the lol
Network oh my god he's I don't even know
this but he's got all the content from a
Def Jam and Wow he's just got a comment
stand up on there he's put a ton of
stand-up special he went out and bought
a bunch of stuff I just like it because
it's it's so true like when you're
trying to look for skin I I like to you
know when I was a kid I that's all I
watched was stand-up so it's it sucks
that these kids don't even know that
there's specials out there but it's like
now they know because of Netflix but
they didn't know that there's yeah two
others on County Central and and now
there's a platform where it's just
showcases that when it was Kevin buying
old specials and putting them on I don't
know if you
shooting specials I think he he also has
new special you know he's kind of like a
premium blend or whatever okay doing
that style it's not some at j FL okay we
get it yes he was shooting some i forget
who we shot and is it all on demand
stuff i don't think so i think it's just
a little screaming wow yes live yeah
that's cool that's so cool that's it
right there right Jim
that's a you see what audience he's
marketing to Katt Williams Gary Owen
all-star Comedy Jam Eddie Griffin Aries
Spears DeRay Davis okay Corey Holcomb
not my audience I'm not going to try to
sell especially Kevin but I had the
Bernie Mac that famous [ __ ] I don't
that that John does not actually not
guarantee I don't think that's the one
at least like let's not burn I'm scare
you [ __ ] yeah yeah that was
such a that that that show was so epic
man I went to one taping when rich boss
was the first white guy on Def Jam and
me and Eric McMahan was a Jersey
comedian buddy of mine we went in saw
wash and I'll never forget Steve Harvey
introduced him and was killed and then
afterwards Steve Harvey what now we're
even like beating for Jackie Robinson
and do you do all the pranks or do you
interview just basically hosting it yeah
yeah than the interview them yeah need
to bring Jim and club soda Kenny on I
don't do pranks see what you did we used
to all that's how you got practice just
[ __ ] annoying our friend what about
meet the creeps or whatever that thing
when Teddy was good those he can keep a
deadpan I could never keep a day he
would at least make me laugh that's why
I would play like I was stellar because
I was slapped me in the face in public
really loud yes called that's called
corpsing yeah we feel scared open a
corpse when you can't we get trying to
stop yourself from what I was so
uncomfortable sure Platina faces I'm
just stunned silence by people I'm like
six foot seven monster just slapped like
a grown man yeah there's the one where
you guys went into the the luggage store
and Kenny just goes into the luggage
store you know club soda Kenny mm-hmm Oh
easily ah
he's a is Jim's road manager security
guy but anyway we even had to dice he's
done stuff with Amy show me some stuff
people but he's like a big just a big
galoot yeah yeah and he just went into a
luggage store and just started cursing
it's the whole time like don't you have
anything a little [ __ ] bigger
well this [ __ ] not going to
work it off and just see how many times
he could curse over and over and over
and over again he's the only guy upset
about luggage
nobody does that no one ever up no no
like this luggage is the same size it's
always been it's empty lucky yeah it's
nice yeah I can't I can't watch myself
just let's play a little bit look well I
don't see it just look at how fat I am
well yeah I just wanted human nah I
don't say that look can we just play a
little bit for joke away he's never seen
club soda Kenny No so Kenny do something
else that's brutal outside keyhole right
sure I don't have a fan that it's like
it's like a garment bag but it's not
just a [ __ ] garment bag it opens up
with some [ __ ] wheels you wear
what [ __ ] sock in college
exactly I hang up in here the answer
your [ __ ] question Colin so I want to
make sure that I get my other one I had
was too small and it wouldn't hold the
[ __ ] the [ __ ] suit and the shirts
I say that's too [ __ ] kidding not
amazing every [ __ ] time I would use
it I would want up with my [ __ ] wrinkled
this [ __ ] thing busted I got your hit
all over the [ __ ] bag I can use it I
still have you spent 300 [ __ ]
[ __ ] backing on it real prizes
which is you buying why don't you let
him get what the [ __ ] line he's playing
side-by-side come on get real now work
it would be quality as far as when it
goes to the airport those [ __ ]
baboons jump all over your luggage to
the centromere wrong with that they're
one of the best fees in the market and
making on that so how much for this
[ __ ] we wanted that [ __ ]
how much these are [ __ ] off that
mustache Kenny can we get two for one
two for one our lives
two for one price clearly I can't do
anything so no you're the [ __ ] boss
you can do what I'm walking here then
you're getting the same Hartmann like
this you're paying a little more pricey
but it's not the quarantine is really
filming like that's all [ __ ] business
and older but you can see how much is it
thousand dollars looking classic that's
all you're paying for this Christ what
quality that number one in the market
that should come with AIDS yes say 50
it's a little high please I'm 9 oh yeah
do you know about the Victoria Secret
bag
what's the Victoria's me I know I don't
know about that I have this victorious
secret bag I have with me on the road
and any time I have it we go through a
crowded area and Airport Jim will shout
ooh
Victoria yeah ah Thank You Millie and
Kenny will scream down a pathway in
Airport
Victoria Secret model coming through and
people [ __ ] look and move because
they don't know what's going on
giant man screaming at them and they're
like where is she yes yes like an
[ __ ] she is so [ __ ] mean by my
courtesy now I know just Kenny got out
Kenny never break she's Amma Kenny's
invested like he literally every time we
would do [ __ ] like that would make me
laugh like I couldn't finish the thing
without going stuck
he's just he's unbreak how much you
offer that [ __ ] yeah
and that's just comfortable for him yeah
and just an uncomfortable man who's ever
gone into that store and referred to a
piece of luggage as a [ __ ] yeah
yeah how much for that [ __ ] right
there yeah nobody's ever said that how
are you on traveling Jim I'm down to one
bag man one bag kara if I'm going away
force if I'm moving I'm doing carry-on
yeah
I wouldn't check a bag ever
I don't like that ever I don't
understand anyone that has to do
something underneath the plane I just
don't get it you guys made fun of me for
not checking bags on my honeymoon when
we were gone for 11 days I don't know
why honeymoon I was a little bit I
didn't let Jess check her bag yeah you
did it was financial that's amazing
Matthew a cheapskate no introduction see
the chisel probably or not but everybody
else 11 days yeah 11 88 Hawaii your
bathing suit jump in the water it's
clean now in registration 11 days a long
time service I've always going for 11
days with a girl I go honey I would
probably do it yeah yeah that's for us
to spend your honeymoon nude anyway
right yeah yeah I mean you got to pack a
lot of rock guy you yeah pack socks you
like to come up
oh my honey where's my comb sock yeah I
do
attack the Comstock yeah they look like
the bottoms of hockey sticks when you're
filming crusty and joke want to promote
jo koy jo it's not Jo why it's Jo KO i
on twitter and jo koat.com if you want
to see Joe is such a funny stand-up and
that has gigs coming up at The Improv
and DC is sold out a bunch of stuff sold
out improv an ox ox nerd and in the
Florida theatre in Jacksonville The
Improv in Chicago is sold out shows a
bunch of [ __ ] sold out so go on go to a
doctor so lame of the tour by the way
[ __ ] tour
are you did you go this week at a DC uh
yeah okay are you going we just added no
yeah it's all though oh yeah that
[ __ ] sold out though Coffee Jim norm
weird sell it for you
Oxnard is uh hard to Sam singing what is
it didn't love Ali no no it's uh Santa
Barbara okay towards that otherwise you
had to play that rule no I don't save it
all you got to play that we're done
Irvine I've done a bunch of I don't
think I've done that one have you played
the new Irvine and the new Brea I don't
know I've never done Brad wait
yeah do in the new oil configure and
renovate it's nice the oxen I want only
buys like a year right oh yeah it's
brand new
I don't know yeah remember we break they
take one more break we'll take a break
yeah I got a pee and Kelsey Trinity
I'm gonna be so you have to pee oh okay
well I always say so yeah Travis just
told me joyously the 10:30 school just
say Oh lieutenant nice yes I will just
say I love it yeah that's the cool thing
about satellite could you do a pocket
your podcast uh it's on Corollas network
yeah it was fun man oh thank you
who's the guy you do with you do a radio
show a radio show that's with my
brother-in-law oh yeah brother yeah I
didn't know that yeah so he's and it's
so funny when you uh you didn't know
someone had a talent oh wow you really
talented let's do this but I don't even
think he knew he could do that but I
think he just filled in one day I
brought him in I was making fun of him
he came in he said I was like oh wait
just sit with me more you could want do
this yeah just do this yeah you can
screw my sister and do this what you get
with jewelry who's your original podcast
partner Michael yo Michael yo he's on
extra and I think you jealousy Excel a
lot I think he might be is Michael yo
doing something here now
maybe I got you I think he is yeah
isn't he do in the afternoon I show on
hits one or something like that's what
he's on yeah I had no idea that he's on
this oh yes yeah that over on hits one
yeah yeah yeah in the afternoons they
did like doing like an afternoon version
of the like morning mashup knowledge ila
yeah so it's him and a girl and a guy
really nice guy man he's he's he's
pretty cool man I like that guy yeah
it's called Hollywood hits Travis ed
nice I know the name I don't know what
he does how we didn't know the name
until Travis says no I heard Michael
yell but I didn't know I didn't know
exactly why I thought you meant
Hollywood hit no um the Hollywood hits
I've ever heard of that sounds like a
million things what Hollywood hits yeah
every David Spade did some show about he
was thought whenever they show us but I
remember uh Hollywood a minute it might
have been Hollywood yeah Vanessa now
that the posters over here don't sure
they changed that into it on comedy
stuff yeah like the poster was so bad
for could be the billboard said doing
say taking the whenever out of
Tinseltown it was some awful slug while
I was in Iran off [ __ ] no think so
under that Kirk cinnamon put up that
yeah darkness the show based show you
makeup anyway baby
that's what it was going I hope it was
ironic yeah yeah maybe David saw that
and today put this do this insult a
that'll be douchey maybe he might done
that purpose actually so speaking of a
radio TV if you haven't talked about it
yet but the year the radio DJ that is
accused of putting his hands all over
Taylor Swift's ass is in court now oh no
I remember I say right because he's
suing I think yesterday was opening
statement I would had to watch this
trial on TV like the OJ trial because
he's suing Taylor Swift because he got
fired because Taylor's show here's the
photo pass that around yeah gosh he is
his radio DJs you know and they were
backstage they did you know the Taylor
Swift meet-and-greet for the radio
station and you can see as well yeah
right on there so Taylor said that he
put his hand up her dress and grabbed
her by the astral I don't know about up
her trip that's what she's like come on
she grabbed a handful and then the radio
station fired him so he said I did not
do that and my reputation has been
besmirched and he's suing Taylor Swift
for like three million dollars but
there's a picture right there and doing
it he's doing it but it's not a perp
dress she's doing anything when she's
moving away from him it could be up her
dress it's not such a short dress I will
say this he's definitely creepy looking
he even if he wasn't doing this go oh he
definitely got an affliction shirt yeah
you might want to sue me too buddy it
doesn't look like he's touching her rib
and it looks like her body language is
moving away from him that's what that's
what he he goes and now she's
countersuing for the legal fees and
everything then again looks like she's
touching his ass too so the picture
might not be accurate let me see that
ah but so uh so what are you talking
about look at the angle of her arm paw
again the crack ah yeah that's okay
because he's saying he's saying that he
he salt her ribs where the ribs ribs is
what he said in court yeah I felt her
River ribs on in her [ __ ] no that's
what he meant the ribs that she ate for
dinner last night yeah they're totally
out of there yeah that was bad you know
what this picture looks like it this
looks like he does morning radio and
heat before he went to this event with
Taylor he was like going to try and you
know I'm gonna see if I can squeeze her
ass right I went crazy yeah do
and he's the local morning show I feel
like he's famous in the town yeah it
doesn't realize outside the town nobody
gives a [ __ ] why would you do that like
a tailless tip is so [ __ ] big yeah if
he did it on purpose like sometimes you
take a picture he's doing and thinking
what the [ __ ] you think yeah there's
only one person more famous and Taylor I
think it's Jesus Christ
yeah Jesus I understand it's just like a
couple hundred thousand so I got Twitter
yeah like a billion yeah right there
yeah JJ so John had so many Fame he's an
ass man though I know love's an ass
cheek you know that's all it is
well here was a that was that happened
in 2013 but like it did you take it out
for years to get the corn that's why
lawyers suck dick because he got fired
and then he had to bring a suit together
and filed suit and then she had to
countersue and then they probably had to
wait awhile I guarantee you her lawyers
they're gonna dream wedding arise idea
push it back in like 2030 yeah she
cannot litigate him forever I guarantee
or her lawyers that's why they're
countersuing to so they can file motions
and that stuff and they'll just keep
doing it does hello until he runs out of
money he seems like he might be kind of
a wreck I guess he was on the stand
yesterday and they asked him because I
guess there's electronic recordings of
the meeting that he had with his bosses
yeah which are important to the case for
whatever reason but everything was
destroyed that they were recorded on so
they go to him and they're like well why
if these are so helpful to you if they
if they make your case why would you
destroy them and he said I did not
destroy them on purpose all that
happened was I accidentally spilled
coffee on my computer I shattered my
iPad by mistake and I broke my iPhone
while I was hiking but really why I
happened on Wednesdays what happened why
does he have all the recordings maybe
secretly recorded it in the meeting I
don't know I don't know but they didn't
say in the article but it's the last
time you spilled anything on your
computer I'm calm yesterday yeah I don't
the last time you spilled anything on
your computer I remember the last time
and then followed that up with
destroying your iPad and iPhone yeah it
never happened
and never ever ever happen know if you
went to the Genius Bar they'd be like
you're lying - yeah yeah not and then I
just burned my house down accidentally I
don't know what the [ __ ] I even caught
on fire yes spontaneous Kommandant
happened was I saying that basically he
doesn't have the evidence that he said
he had that picture is very dead she
says hello feel her rib he said I felt
her rib I guarantee he told everybody he
was going to do it and I thought it
would be funny on the radio and she was
just like haha like she know they were
gonna take it this one that's his
girlfriend photo is that hands act his
girlfriend right his hand up her ass I
mean and that looks bad he's in there
though I've been there and that dress is
short enough that he could easily just
go like down three inches and then back
up and maybe she maybe she said if she
said that out of the blue I can't see
why she would say that out of the blue
and then that picture those two things
together don't make sense right look at
the girlfriend though having the time of
her life she has no idea no she does you
think magical you know she looks like
she looks like the kind of chick that
like when you go to the town to perform
she's like you know everyone calls me
the Chelsea Handler this city I get that
all the time there's always that one
blonde that's like you know in her late
50s still drunk
Tellis added yeah yeah I don't have a
filter yeah
we should get one yeah she's doing him
for a dollar why just so there can be a
suing him for $1 and for the legal is
all you have to put an amount and then
the legal fees so she's gonna ask for
legal fees at the end yes oh I think the
dollar is so what you're saying so she
can final motion I love it really draw
this thing out really fast like a dollar
please yeah and that there's a reason
for that it's obvious I'm gonna sue you
for $1 not a write that check out you
gotta get settled it loose whip yeah $1
dollar head just give it to her in which
you write okay Julian because he's the
one suing her her dollars a countersuit
yeah it's a counter he's trying to get
three million out of her and he probably
thought that she would just settle cause
it's going to be so negative the
publicity
heap I thought she'd set up right and
she ain't a fighter
affected with that picture floating
around if it's true she's probably like
this guy touch my ass I'm not settling I
got about litigate this guy forever
decided I push those chip now I think
we're just go in what do you
yeah yeah this is a they're a trash
couple she's wearing those like
bedazzled jeans you know he's been right
away you think they're swingers me was
like convincing her because he's like
hot [ __ ] in the town he's a guy get
Taylor to come home with us on it so do
you think maybe he thought he got vibes
off Taylor who knows
she's sexy and yeah what kind of life is
yeah she would never give in vibe you
know she might flirt during interviews
I've had people flirt during interviews
we just were just trying to sell a
product and that's when I learned
performers I'll tell you know we were
just flirt so you don't really want this
dick out yeah they put that back in my
dad yeah i winked at me though I thought
that meant blue jaw you don't want me to
finger you with a turd fall out my dad
Taylor Swift does have that effect of
she smiled at me once and like instantly
I was like I think we maybe we could be
boyfriend-girlfriend I think yeah I
think that could happen yeah I'm looking
for a nice guy in there also I can show
her what a real relationship is know all
about Hollywood hoopla I bet you
couldn't set it I talked to her for 10
seconds and in my head I'm already like
and then that was it with a 10-second
interaction and I was like I think I'll
be we're feeling this wounded I got it
are we in while I know we're is this
what I because you want to wear my pin
do I touch you or just touch any the
private if it's not crazy what's
happening right now me kids right now to
bring that ass over here let me grab
that out what time is dinner I already
know what I'm going to say if I have a
meter what what you know when I first
heard me I thought you wrote it about me
and my experiences how could you want to
be oh just like my experiences that's
terrible fate one more time you know
when you first wrote me I thought you
were writing that about me and my
experiences life and where we create and
that's how you're going to stand to the
three-peat I just got one hand in a
pocket yeah so both my hands open
Campbell my stomach that way yeah for
the first time in your life not blinking
yeah just dead stare stare I'm gonna I'm
gonna give it the old boo radley a shot
guy oh yeah so it was about me who you
picked on I was I was well what happens
is it to this guy outside a radio though
that's pretty much it I mean that's it's
that was because he probably thought
like okay I need radio anymore I mean
you get three million bucks yeah you
know I'm going to go to his studies
right now we're going to go to cabo
right yeah that's like so that's the
extent of his goals we're going to go to
Cabo Cabo he knows [ __ ] let's do this
but I wanted to Taylor Swift [ __ ]
clear million dollars buys a lot of
mojito a lot of mojito these are the
kind of guys that don't do taxes in
their head take that three million last
forever
no leave area legal fees no they're go
taxes aren't athlete neither LeBron what
do you mean I'm broke I got three
million dollars but it'd be another
mojito I get a bill from the IRS for 1.5
million dollars I guess I spent it
already
yeah when doin cheap I bet he [ __ ] when
he said oh she's countersuing cuz you
she wants legal fees and something tells
me her lawyers cost more than his was it
yeah this meet and greet picture where
it looks like your hand is on her ass
yeah yeah yeah this is gonna hurt your
case top yeah this is where you stuck
three fingers in a bubble yeah we have
it on film yeah yeah you know it's legit
aquarium Z's on there oh yeah yeah do it
they aren't anything [ __ ] they watermark
that [ __ ] yeah now that's there I love
TMZ I'm sorry you do I'm they've kind of
grown on me tonight I love them man when
I learned that certain times that they
won't when I got to know Adam the
cameraman he's like now a lot of times
they don't [ __ ] with people if they
really want to be [ __ ] with yeah like
what I've learned if they do lay off a
lot like and have more than half most of
it is paid anyway like it's all a
negotiation like they're never gotten
paid for being on TMZ I've been on many
times I've never been paid
well you have to ask to be on to you
know I don't I don't know let's say
that's a different deal no they know
they're like you want to come on we need
some big celebrities I'm like all right
Sam are they charging you I'm saying
yeah don't you have to pay to be on CNN
ACM TMZ uh hundred bucks you want to be
honest like yeah it's cold come Sox no I
know a lot of people have gotten paid by
a I'm sure I have not
I love TMZ men I just hate their banter
I just think he was out there on the
office yeah I hate that what is that
call the writers room yeah yeah
I can just bantering it's a great format
for a show yeah I wouldn't mind
co-hosting that show that guys alright
yeah
forgive me reverently now just a
temporary Oh for how long
no ever they want are you still in
Taylor Swift character right now no I
creepy Jim right yeah I'm always creepy
here now I'm just I'm just uh he's
putting the Hollywood vibes out there
you know works in show business ask me
they know I mentioned on the air that oh
yeah but I wasn't there
yes they actually asked me to do if I
wasn't there she's gonna jump on you bet
I will good I was watching the UH news
you can have one of them dad that's like
that so Joe poison the news Joe what's
going on I'd be so bad I'm gonna bring
it it's not natural at all yeah yeah
natural all the gym yeah like this Kanye
right - what's the TMZ sound
unbelievable yeah yeah we have it that's
hard
what's his name Harvey Levin hard yeah
yeah Jews oh you did she I used to hate
him too but then the more I've learned
about him I like this guy's a smart dude
yeah any made a business out of it yeah
man yeah and I love how he plays down
that he's a lawyer I'm a lawyer
yeah I'm a douchey lawyer I'm a lawyer
he uh would you have your own like cup
like you know they have those office
coffee cups no I would drink my patented
thing there's no ice left in this but I
would drink like an icy coffee and I
would do that like but the ice did it
sounded nice yeah yeah I don't know I
mean they saw her buy a lipstick but who
knows she was supposed to be out with
her husband no she hit faster huh you
know that is good is good yeah i
Kardashians Jesus Christ for that coming
for pete's sake good yeah you guys use
old man expressions that's what I would
you ever like thing on TMZ so Kim you
and Kanye are fighting heavens to Betsy
tell us what's going - to bed consensus
show decels on the road
heavens to Betsy Young's to bed and the
H has an arrow pointing up seven I love
it yeah cool swag you have people open
up there snap apt if so he says it real
quick yeah I have been dancing you
should do that you should used to come
up with a joke where heavens to Betsy is
the punchline and then right after you
say the punchline just be like by the
way these heavens to Betsy t-shirts are
going to be available right up
I got one better Sam he closes his show
and he yelled out to the crowd heavens
and the crowd responds I'm looking for
luggage and it's ready to leave that's
great yeah yeah any sells luggage yeah
that's what he sells we've done the
looking for luggage to her yeah yeah
have you thought it have you come up
with it or a name for your tour yet I
have is they're looking for luggage now
what is it you kneeling room only you
can keep it kneeling getting room only
that's good okay I love it watch out
joke I love it yeah there's all the way
to what else you guys closure or maybe
it's worship maybe it's like exactly or
maybe it's coat or licking okay I like
to see on my knees you need a cooter
yeah that like being on their needs when
they're encoded long you're looking at
cooter yeah I like [ __ ] turning their
sideways and just [ __ ] flopping lips
oh my god it okay yeah I calculate if I
have an organic farmer my comrade yeah
these regret I know for God's sake what
is this by the way into yourself right
now
Wow didn't bring a change of the UH
atrocious what is this video you're
talking about this is real video Dan in
Chicago telescopes yeah this YouTube
video of this Taylor Swift's got its
effect on guys
she's got this pudgy little fifty year
old guy standing outside of her hotel
she was going to ash or whatever and
he's yelling at her hey did you get my
note Taylor to get my note Taylor okay
we're looking at fan Thanks sorry facts
an yelling note yeah totally angrily
yelling either I didn't knows
good-naturedly
what's what angrily yelling at her no
just somebody yelling at her seeing if
they got it his note that's all sad yeah
give a write a letter to a Hannah
Liberty now never it's gonna be the
worst thing they do they gave written
money and no not many by did when I was
a kid how old you I'm 48 I'm 46
oh you might okay so I was I wanted to
meet Ozzie I was growing up so jet
records in England I sent them a note
asking for like an autograph or whatever
or I yeah I've wrote a few letters too
slow oh yeah I wrote the Church of Satan
when I was a teenager oh that's so cool
yeah really yeah I asked them to put a
spell on this girl and make her like me
how you doing
yeah I know my god what well I did a
worst thing I've ever heard over you 20
1960 new or 16 I was yeah I was drinking
I was drunk
oh yeah do you got drunk and wrote a
letter to the churches yeah I'm gonna
get my Miss 15 was there all my little
too old ah yeah you're right
oh [ __ ] yeah that is so funny I wish I
still had the note just crying when I
wrote it you know who has it
Satan yeah has it raining crotch rip
there's some girl was just in love with
you get a spell was put on her bye see
ya gentle help me yeah you were crying
when you wrote it yeah I was drunk I was
like in knowledge dramatic I wanted this
girl lobbying she didn't
Jim you shouldn't animate this right now
and have a caption respond like this big
all you see is a big red head do Jim I
feel your pain I will make sure her
[ __ ] burned for years yes I was
rejected once by my father
cash me out I know it feels like to be
of a suburban North Brunswick nerd I
also have erection difficulty tango
because I don't know my identity isn't
that the same chairs the same problems
with you like it's great yes I've
questioned my own sexuality this is the
same pornography you have Jim but you
know what Jim just [ __ ] Abby and 25
years they'll say gender-fluid you want
your sister somebody's definitely seen
tonight sky is a good idea precisely
where he burns people but he likes me
can I'm almost too pathetic for the
devil to kill yeah it's like a yeah
douche bag he's got nothing yeah well I
did Jim is Jesus Christ dope popular I
hate him as much yeah Paul can't fight
him and Taylor Swift yeah I just grabbed
her ass right dead damn yeah Jim in the
dead yeah give me in the dead I had when
I was at me in it when I was a boy I had
pledged the soul to a place to state and
I signed it my own blood and hung it on
my bedroom door you did
hi you know what the [ __ ] was going on
in your house I was a little fresh boy
who needed attention
nobody wanted your soul Jim nobody 100
naughty dog they not even Satan